General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a TR
rre I'm not built like other
[Music]
men move along now those in power only
see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office like witches at black m but I
follow in the footsteps of Alexander the
Great and
Caesar evil minds at plot destruction if
you look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it Sorcerer of death
construction I must warn you I will not
lead a second in
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
[Music]
head
as you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without this
[Music]
ver who country here we
[Applause]
in
mine